[Music]
it's hard being a reporter
but if it were easy everyone would want
to do it right
right
[Music]
afternoon comrades who are you guys
vigilantes for truth
we're very entrepreneurial i'm in high
school now okay things are gonna be
different i don't want them to be
different
you have to start doing some normal kid
stuff oh my god
are those dead
i thought i'd already written the most
important story of my life
but this was bigger
[Music]
this town there are all sorts of rules
you gotta play by
[Music]
i think something in erie harbor is
making people sick and they've been
covering this up for years
messages
oh my god and i ain't got nothing to say
if we don't figure out what they're
covering up everyone in this town could
be in danger
we're not gonna let that happen
seriously he'll be you're like some old
person reddit feed
like inside my house does something
happen somewhere
this could be how we find richie he saw
something and that's why he got taken
baby
criminal trespassing on a school night
but in a purposeful way for a good cause
you need to get control of your daughter
[Music]
we have no idea what these people are
capable of
the hardest stories to cover are the
ones you care most about
we're young but we are not stupid
they cannot stop her from speaking the
truth
you